first thing we start off with is we
create a variable here called render
engine class and you define a variable
by starting with the keyword var and
then the variable name and then you say
equals whatever you'd like to be equal
to in this case we use an opening brace
to indicate that we'd like this to be a
JavaScript object this is the object
literal notation for defining an object
in JavaScript from there we can declare
methods and member variables of that
object by specifying the name of the
member a colon and then the value that
it's going to take in this case we
declare the method to have the name draw
string we use a colon and then we say
that this is going to be a function we
use the keyword function to define this
and then we give a list of all the
parameters and then open the function
with an opening brace similarly to how
you would in many other languages now
again we create a variable named it and
then assign to it the value of G render
engine doc context now this is going to
take the JavaScript object G render
engine and the dot notation is going to
tell us that we want the context member
of this object and we do something
similar down here where we grab the font
member of the CTX object and assign it
this value here now you notice that
we're using addition and strings
addition is overloaded in JavaScript to
also designate string concatenation
again similar to a lot of other
languages you might have seen next we
have an example of an if statement if
statements work essentially the same way
that they would in any other language
where you have at the keyword if then in
parentheses you specify the predicate
that's going to return a boolean value
either true or false and then the body
of the if statement that executes if
that evaluates to true now note that the
statement here doesn't have braces
around it designating what executes if
the if statement evaluates to true this
is similar to some other languages where
if there is a single line that you need
to evaluate you don't require those
braces we use this here they're just for
readability purposes so you might see
this in the code now
for larger if blocks you can delineate
them with an opening brace
and then once they are done way down
here you close them with another brace
from there we have a number of more
examples of declaring and setting
variables and then we come to a for loop
for loops are structured essentially the
same way they are in C where we have an
initializer value than a predicate to
evaluate for when the for loop should
end and then an expression to execute at
the end of each for loop and similarly
to you if blocks the block of code that
you'd like to execute each time the for
loop runs is delineated by braces
although again if it's a single line you
don't require those braces to be there
now here we see words and where n is in
square braces and again n is the
variable that our for loop is looping
over this is an example of accessing a
list where n is the nth element in that
list now like most other languages this
is 0 indexed as well so keep that in
mind